alors jean paul rouve au prix d'une
maison neuve à vos parents et/ou affaire
on n'en passe pas fille et je ferai pas
aller pour faire lorsque mes parents
sont pauvres et j'ai envie qu'il le
reste
c'est pas bien de changer ils sont trop
vieux pour changer dans des cartons à ta
mère prend qu'à dorment dans la rue ça
m'a changé de statut à leur âge trop
traumatisant la drogue et les plus de
faits ou à faire dans la drogue non je
suis même pas de pétard tu vois je ne
fume pas je picole un peu mais
tranquille et les [ __ ]
est ce qu'une fille qui couche avec moi
ce que je suis connu ça fait une chute à
la la c'est ça c'est ça lentement
grenadine du chef d'équipé ou affaires
n'ont pas fait dire tu alain delon fait
ou à faire affaire non à faire je vais
rencontrer mais j'ai l'impression qu'il
avait eu une fiche sur moi avant se
faire inviter par arthur à saint tropez
feu aux affaires n'ont jamais fait non
plus et je n'ai pas envie d'aller à
saint tropez gagner un césar fait ou à
faire ainsi ça c'est classe si trop
cassé un start est hélas dans ce groupe
où mme tu montes coucher avec une fille
juste majeur fait ou à faire avec ton
césar toujours couché avec une fille
juste besoin de bonnes majeur touché
qu'une fille juste réfé fait faire la
bise à catherine de la fée ou à faire
non je connais pas claquer un million
d'euros en un mois fait ou à faire un
million de roubles 1 mois ou avec
catherine deneuve ça va vite trouver une
inconnue à poil dans votre lycée ou à
faire un nom à faire j'aimerais bien s'y
connaître
mais c'est ce soir avon qui abat et
arriver inconnu évidemment forcément je
sais pas si c'est parler de son film aux
20 heures chez claire chazal fait ou à
faire dimanche blanche alors elle parle
du cinéma un film et on est au 20 heures
dimanche de quelque chose at dans le
sahel après tout se faire offrir en
entrant dans un magasin de fringues fait
ou à faire c'est entre les deux c'est à
dire que c'est un peu minable et là ils
me disent venez on va vous filer des
trucs
il m'offre un truc et après ils disent
le reste on nous fait 30%
ouais ouais c'est un peu 1001 principe
logique 2002 des toiles se faire payer
en liquide pour une soirée privée effet
wafeer annonce le nom pour faire quoi
dans sera privé pour y être
allons bon georges slim est sauté une
animatrice télé fait ou à faire
jean-paul arlette chabot ses consignes à
patrice
la couverture de recife où affaire non
pas si j'aimerais bien je serai cet été
cela nu sur la plage de dunkerque alors
donné son opinion sur un sujet de
société fait ou à faire alors à faire la
prostitution alors jean paul wahl et
[ __ ] je peux pas - ou alors gratos
drapeau c'est en diffamation ont fait ou
à faire oui elle fait avec les robins
bataille avoir un coach personnel fait
ou à faire ah non à faire un peu le vois
ça tu n'as pas de préparateur physique
et j'ai pu manger pas très j'ai hâte à
toi ouais il bosse beaucoup d'heures
personnel la part de loin c'est un
boulot dire non à un rôle dans le
prochain film d'alain chabat a fait ou à
faire non je pourrais pas ça ouais il
joue fermé à jouer au poker et patrick
bruel fait ou affaires à faire affaire à
avoir plus de trois partenaires sexuels
différents la même semaine fées ou à
faire un aussi grand coeur non mais si
je parle d'un temps que les moins de 20
ans évidemment la cac
c'était avant c'était non mais c'est
vrai aussi soutenir à l'homme politique
fait ou à faire au nom je repose la
commencer une phrase en disant écoutez
moi qui suis acteur écouter nos tissus
acteurs non j'ai pas fait ça mais je me
suis surpris quelquefois être idiot des
trucs qui m'ont énervé bêtement où je me
suis dit mais c'est pas normal avec
chouity est en fait une deux secondes
après je lui dis mais je suis qui en
fait
à